your videos rolling audacity's rolling
yeah and if you want me i'll do another
slap of the hands so that video and
audio are synced up where are you phil i
am in
house in nottingham so um like everybody
else locked down and um having a
fun time
being socially distanced let's put it
that way
yeah how about you brady i'm i'm the
same i'm locked in a room editing videos
but that's what i normally do anyway
yeah i'm getting a lot of writing done
so it's it's not so bad you know
obviously a lot of people are
you know suffering in terms of you know
family members etc i've got to admit my
family's okay um
even my more elderly relatives are okay
so you know it could be a lot worse i'm
getting some writing done i'm getting
some
you know the usual standard my inbox is
just as full if not more full than it
used to be so um
in some ways
this is you know surreal in other ways
it's almost business as usual phil a lot
of scientists and mathematicians i spoke
to when the lockdown starter said this
is great i can catch up on lots of
writing and papers that i've been
sitting in a drawer for months but then
they've been telling me i've been stuck
on so many zoom calls and meetings and
other administrative things that take
lots of time i'm getting even less work
than done than before on the right-hand
side that's that's a good point brady
that's how that's really how i feel um
and it's not just it's not just the zoom
calls and the the that side of things
it's there's something about the the
atmosphere and the environment and the
la the lack of structure sometimes to
the day
that certainly i feel my my productivity
has gone down but you know productivity
isn't everything as i say you know
healthy and and well so i've got to
count blessings as it were um and the
other thing as well as i'm sort of glad
i don't spend as much time on social
media as i used to because i'm sure i'd
get very sick of people going look at
this thing i made and look at this thing
i cooked and look at this thing i
painted and look at i've solved all the
world's problems in during lockdown that
could get very infuriating after a
little while i think phil how did the
timing of the lockdown come for you in
terms of what was happening in your labs
like were you were you on the brink of a
great discovery was it a good time for
the lab to have to close down anyway or
no no it's never a good time for the lab
to close down i was actually on research
leave at the university of alberta i was
in canada with bob walco's lab when when
the whole sort of
lockdown started and i had to cut that
research leave short and come back
instead of spending two weeks in
edmonton university of alberta i had to
come back uh a week early um so and then
the labs are completely shut down the
pumps aren't even running on the vacuum
system so we'll be doing a lot of baking
when we go back after the lockdown
can you just explain what you mean by
you'll have to do a lot of baking i
thought i thought everyone was doing
their baking now while they're stuck at
home
yeah so for us um to get a very very
good vacuum we have to heat the entire
ultra high vacuum system up to 150
degrees
and we call that process baking and
after there's going to be prolonged
period when the systems will be not
pumped they're at a static what we'd
call a static vacuum so they're sitting
there in principle the vacuum should be
okay-ish but they'll certainly need to
be baked to get back to the levels of
vacuum that we really really need to
start the experimental program again
when that happens i don't know
nobody knows really purely from a
science perspective
how catastrophic is this for science i
know a lot of industries this is like
this is killing a lot of industries
is science a bit more resilient to this
kind of shutdown this is obviously going
to halt science for um quite some time
you know exp i'm an experimentalist
we can do some work obviously in terms
of computer simulations we're working
with machine learning so that can happen
offline but in terms of experiments no
experiments are happening at the moment
for experimental postdocs and for
experimental researchers that's a that's
a real issue and um
hopefully you know they're going to be
able to get back in the lab and
hopefully it'll be in terms of when
university research starts up again i
would very much hope it would be the
experimentalists who would be getting
back you know
allowed back on campus um first because
they are the ones that are really
suffering from you know not being able
to have access to the science they can
do
we do a lot of sales i see a lot of
simulations we love machine learning so
that can happen offline and
that can happen away from the campus but
um the core of what we do is basically
just entirely shut down at the moment
phil a lot of industries have been able
to keep working as long as they're very
careful about how they locate their
people is the reason you've had to shut
your lab because of a university
directive to stay off campus or did you
think your lab couldn't work
specifically uh it's a university
directive it's a school directive we
we're off campus i will see how that
goes over the next few weeks in terms of
a staged sort of reintroduction or
staged
allowance and getting people back into
the lab um
in urlab i think we could have a
mechanism whereby we'd ensure that there
were you know just one person in the lab
and we could have shifts and people
could come in and social distancing
could still be um
you know going on um the problem is
though of course is when that's not just
our lab when it's every lab in the in
the department on every lab in the
university then
i can understand the university's
concerns then it becomes a lot more
difficult to manage could our lab
continue absolutely but um we're not the
only lab there phil i know recently
you've been having a big role at the
university with admissions of new
students
and
that seems to be something that has been
on your mind a bit about how this
shutdown is affecting student intake the
new students current students can you
tell me about where your concerns have
been and how they've been resolving in
your head so i was under as you say i
was undergraduate admissions tutor which
means that i oversaw
applications from high school students
from secondary school students a level
students ap physics students etc etc um
into our courses i did that for five
years last year i passed that role over
to my colleague megan gray many of you
and 60 symbols will know megan very well
and deep sky videos will know megan very
well megan and i obviously have the same
um concerns but what
and
we are would want to just want to get
the message out there to those students
who are obviously going to be worried
they haven't they won't be doing the
exams like previous students have they
might be a little bit worried about um
just how what it's going to be like the
first year at university and of course
we don't want you to panic we don't want
you to worry we are well aware that of
course this is a completely different
unprecedented situation surreal in many
ways
and we of course are gonna make um you
know make sure that we take account of
that it feels like there are two issues
here
one is how you're going to decide which
students get admitted if they haven't
taken the normal exams
and the second issue is for the ones you
do take in what is their level of
preparedness going to be in terms of you
know their underlying mathematical and
physics ability because they've missed
the last part of their final year of
school first of all in terms of how you
decide who to admit do you even know how
that's going to be done yet or is that
being decided by other powers or we have
some idea that's obviously going to be
the sky that's cited by by government
overall department of education overall
it will be on a levels are not going
ahead in the uk um even gcic exams
are not going ahead so we it will have
to be on the basis of predicted grades
it will have to be in the basis of
whatever coursework is available to help
this teachers make decisions etc and we
are just going to have to take those uh
predicted grades on board and make our
decisions on the basis of those those
grades um megan can tell you a lot more
about this i must admit i am not
i do not envy at all megan's situation
at the moment in terms of being an
admissions tutor during this particular
period um but as i said that's that's
largely what we're going to have to do
um with regard to preparedness my the
key message i want to get across is
don't panic the best douglas adams
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy where
do not panic we are well aware that
these are unprecedented circumstances we
are well aware that students are going
to be really anxious and nervous in
terms of well i haven't done the the
exams i haven't had the same preparation
as other years have had we know that and
um just thought it would be a good idea
to you know
suggest a few things just to keep the
brains taking over in terms of lockdown
so everybody doesn't go stir crazy
everybody doesn't start crawling the
walls in terms of what physics you could
do the type of things that we might
recommend i hope i hope you're going to
recommend 60 symbols phil
absolutely the first on my list brady is
of course 60 symbols on all those other
wonderful brady harren channels
including number file and deep sky
videos and periodic videos even though
it causes me great pain to have to
mention the chemists but there we go um
yes so definitely there are all those
wonderful uh online resources there are
there are other videos on physics that
you can find other than brady's other
channels yeah other channels are
available exactly i may well if it's
okay with you brady i'm gonna write up a
short blog post on this and i'll just
put a range of different links in in
there i guess the first thing
to say is is sort of you know keep on
keep on doing what you like about
physics you know keep on you know
watching those videos but also reading
and i can certainly recommend a whole
host of different books there are a
couple of websites i'd really like to
recommend though first of all there's
something called um isaac physics
isaac has an isaac newton which is a
university of cambridge based uh online
project founded funded by the ogden
trust which is also actually funded 60
symbols in the past
and um
that's a really great resource for um
preparing
both at a level but also in at
university level so if you want to get
an idea or you want to get some um
physics problems and thinking about just
where the the level is going to be when
you enter university it's really well
worth taking a look at isaac's physics
it's also quite fun the institute of
physics also has a really great site
which is called spark.iop.org
in terms of what else can you do beyond
online resources
and and reading of course
one thing i would suggest
really heavily suggest for those of you
who are into coding code
and for those of you who aren't into
coding
start coding
honestly you will it's fine it's great
fun it can be infuriating at times but
in terms of really
focusing you in terms of
learning real physics and how to code
that physics and and to write a physics
simulation that's really good
preparation for any university degree
and moreover it's really good in terms
of understanding the court the core
physics as an undergraduate um
i and i've said this before in in other
videos brady but it's better it's worth
repeating my mantra was if i can't code
it i don't understand it because for
coding a simulation or coding a piece of
physics really focuses you down on what
are the core aspects here it's a whole
wide range of different projects i could
suggest um and even sort of the the
mathematical side
away from the physics there's things
like the mandelbrot set there's things
like the cube roots of unity fractals
there's a whole wide range of really fun
projects you could do that will keep
your math skills um up to up to grade as
well just reading between the lines
there
i feel like i feel like maybe you're
even suggesting sometimes when students
come through from school at the best of
times maybe they could turn up their
coding a little bit
i yeah absolutely um so your math skills
are important but also it's increasingly
important to to start getting into
coding skills and obviously computer
file is a great place to start but as
well as watching videos it's like
learning a musical instrument
particularly with coding but also
particularly with physics
you have to you know it's practice and
it's it's it's the difference between
sort of passively watching a video and
actively doing something and that
actively doing something will really
sort of embed these ideas and
a huge area not just in physics but in
all of the sciences in right across the
board out of science in economics in
practically every areas of obviously
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and
so much of physics is now at that
interface with with computer science in
terms of machine learning and that's you
know there are quite a few sites out
there and there's some great um computer
file videos on on neural nets and
machine learning and thinking about how
that translates into physics is is also
um something very worthwhile to do
there's a great book by the way actually
i've got it here so this great book
which is not so much about the details
of the algorithms etc etc but it's a
really good read in terms of machine
learning and um called red's inside the
machine by a guy called robert smith not
the singer in the cure the band the cure
but actually a professor at ucl at
university college london and that's
that's well worth a read in terms of the
broader scope of how many areas machine
learning is feeding into is there a
particular language that one should pick
up if one's going to just start saying
okay i'm going to learn to code where
there's so i thought there are a whole
bunch of languages out there python is a
good place to start python's open source
it's freely available it's a really good
place to start um but even
i i like i've started to get back into
javascript quite a lot javascript is a
lot of fun because you can embed
simulations into a browser and in fact
all you need for javascript is
basically notepad on a browser that's
really it and that then you can start
coding that when it's a lot of fun you
can tweak you can really set up an
environment you can have
buttons and sliders and change the
parameters and you know there are things
like
diffusion there are sort of some
standard standard projects which are
still a lot of fun
in terms of diffusion limited
aggregation the icing model there's a
that of you know even things like that
simple pendulum
if you apply a force to it you can code
that and actually that would behave
chaotically not randomly chaotically in
the true physics sense it's it's it's
it's a really neat manifestation of
chaos that project alone that piece of
code alone on the simple pendulum a
driven simple pendulum that could keep
you going for days you know and in fact
that's you know that's often one of the
projects that's set at an undergraduate
level as well so um there's a range of
different different projects and what
i'll do is i'll in the blog post i'll
i'll list a few of these phil
the lockdown as we record now hasn't
been going for that long it's been a few
weeks
and i know most school students are
still having interaction with their
teachers via technology and and home
learning
i feel
how much can they be missing out on in
their last few weeks of school and if
it's been topped up by home learning i
mean this can't be that big a problem
oh no it's quite it's a it's it's a it's
a pretty big problem well first of all
the exams not happening is is
a big problem and so there's not that
intense drive and there's not that
intense motivation um at this end of the
school year for gcses and a levels my
daughter's actually at gcse she would
have been doing her gcse exams this year
and in terms of a level students it's
exactly the same so it's not this same
drive they are doing homework the
teachers are doing an incredible job in
keeping them motivated etc but with the
best will in the world they're not going
to the classroom the day isn't just
structured they it's not the same
environment it's not the same sort of
overall ethos
so
and
again i'm even finding it sometimes in
terms of productivity and motivation
very very difficult so you know students
are also going to find that in in under
these circumstances so
um it is very different i would say
compared to previous years and a lot of
stuff gets crammed in does it in those
in those last months and gets like
solidified in your brain that is like
that is a key time is that
yes it is these last few months when the
run-up to exams are absolutely key
absolutely when do when
you have to excuse my ignorance when
would new students be starting if
everything like best case scenario i
know there's so much doubt around
everything at the moment but best case
scenario when will the new
students come in
it would be that it's the it's the
second last week of september for us it
varies a little bit across the uk but
for nottingham it would be the second
last week in september would be the sort
of induction week and then lectures
would start last week of september right
at the beginning of october
whether we're going to hit that
is big
big uncertainty we'll get people on the
case i'll link to your blog and all the
stuff that people can look at
um one last question then while
everyone's locked down it's always a
good chance to
explore new music any music
recommendations
oh oh wow wow wow thank you for that
pretty so myself and a couple of friends
uh james and pete have been playing this
game which is recommend a new band or a
new album um uh every uh every day i'm
giving you 10 minutes phil i'm giving
you 10 minutes
um oh there's a there's a whole host of
new music one of my favorite new bands
is a band called wilderron who managed
to mix the most metal of metal
blast beats etc with folk music
basically and um
pink floyd harmonies for anybody who's a
fan of opeth i
recommend wilder on their boston band um
in terms of old albums if you haven't
heard of kings x go out and get download
beg borrow stealing album called out of
the silent planet and if there's a third
recommendation jellyfish absolute power
pop band 90s or a huge debt to lenin and
mccartney but then who doesn't but they
do the beatles better than the beatles
did the beatles you'll understand when
you hear the albums club absolutely
class man all right thank you for that
brady you heard it here first thank you
for thank you professor moriarty and
for your words of words of wisdom
thank you brady thanks a lot good luck
x-ray optics and we need to be able to
get those x-rays onto our sample to
focus them down the synchrotron is about
10 billion times brighter than the sun
so this is an immense engineering
challenge